this video is sponsored by better help
as three people who are proud to be in
therapy we are proud to be sponsored by
these guys citizens of the reject Nation
it is time for Loki season 2 episode 5
today after last week's Cliffhanger
cannot wait to see how they completely
resolve everything in one episode no no
I'm excited to see what's going on John
how are you I am lowy forward to this G
okay not bad not bad I am highkey
excited to be enthralled I am yes yes um
I've been on a jet ski before leave a
like leave a like subscribe click the
notification get notified when a
reaction for the last episode of the
season is up here on this channel thank
you to everyone who's been buying some
RR merch that means the world we're all
wearing some RR merch he got a lowy one
hell yeah I'm talking about last but not
least massive thank to all who have been
supporting us at our patreon becoming
super sexy regz that's where you get the
full length Reaction watch along for
Loki where you SN up with your own copy
over there we cover several shows
exclusively with highlights and watch
Longs included all righty gang let's see
what's going
on jet skis seos one of these calling
your name Mobius I don't know about
calling is this the episode of jet skis
are we going to Mobius his
timeline what's the over under on Victor
timely getting spaghetti meaning Kang
now has his power because he's become
part of time itself I think that's how
he conquers time I think that was the
path I'm not sure Victor timely is
permanently gone honestly saying I think
that Kang put timely on the path to
becoming mom spaghetti to be Time Lord
of mom spaghetti the Palm sweat is
time love this 2001 of Space Odyssey
Marvel
bumper for boing sounds of
mourning where are you waking up is he
in some void the
construct still in the
TVA alone where's all the pie did he
time slip is he Beyond time he's the
only
God low key who remains Sylvie was a God
but I don't know if they can be on the
same cool jump
cut damn the matching on the editing is
phenomenal here and they're all like
moving shots
29 fail sa mode initi fail safe mode
time there it is okay so it is what's
happening oh go to the location the shot
that I oh damn where is
everybody oh hey
me what does he learn
hello
H that must be a later moment we're
going to see him hear
him it doesn't look that far in the
future or past
though now he's going to pick up the
book He's only slipping by a little bit
I think I think the bigger the
Distortion the shorter the
slip
hello good call Koy nicely done big
Distortion short time that's why it was
only like a hallway jump
oh oh no I thought time might be
converging but it looks like it's fully
splitting temporal
fungus oh we're going to get this shot
I'm been waiting for I feel it oh match
with it is
it fail fail mode what did he
plan oh miss minutes is in control I
love these visual oh that was a genius
open that was Fant fantastic please wake
up in front of the store I've been
waiting for the shot now wake up at jet
ski shot J shot oh the letters they're
going away they're we're going to have a
singi I think it's going to be a
singularity I think we're going to have
one are we getting Prime timeline in
show causing them to need to find prime
timeline people in Deadpool
3 let's just see what
happens
casy casy KY King the
[Music]
conquer what time prison have they
locked you
in the greatest Ste very much
[Music]
so SpongeBob's waking up oh this is
probably Casey's real life oh you're
right this is going to be Casey's life
damn
we're out of the TVA now we're going to
find out we're going to see Owen Wilson
with a jet ski next we're going to see
people's lives 19
1962 are we on Alcatraz it's said Branch
timeline Casey I got you here his name's
not Casey who are
you not again how'd you get here how did
I get
where elcat what yes I don't know what's
happening Casey Frank why is this guy
calling you Casey been calling you Frank
the whole time you got to find your own
way off this rock sorry
pal man Frank's a dick
[Music]
yeah that's one way I like this night
photography you can I actually see there
it
is J now I have to call a
thing what point is time is this it's
the time theater from the first season
which we didn't see in this season is it
when he's about to watch himself and
like okay so we got a good cast on here
for you he she was a pediatrician you
might forget how bad it hurt over the
next 6 weeks so I'm going to write a
little reminder on
[Music]
here life is
pain I wonder if the climbing tree thing
will come back tree branches
timelines
where are we I Wonder Why the he's
Tethered to
them because they were all there at the
same time
yeah it's
happening get that wind I can die he's
sitting in front of a green screen or
something in a phot he's in a photo
shoot open in front of
you
yes so talk to me Cleveland Ohio who's
more interested in a dirt bike well they
say the personal watercraft is kind of
the thinking man's dirt
bike jump up on this bad boy I'm good
sorry call me if you change your mind
this is so cathartic great Donuts today
[Music]
Dale wacky waving inflatable arm
flailing Tube Man how could he not get
up here Dale crazy I don't get it you're
here every day of the week except Sunday
9 to 5 career man the
TVA is gone I think you mean ATV
[Music]
and you don't remember me either no I do
you were in just the other day right
your son's on line three sorry single
dad a sing single dad he has a son your
other son f as once tell I'll call him
back too Papa Mobi two sons that's why I
didn't want to know wow he seems like he
has the exact EXA same
personality OB Pasadena Great Library
this is our tank contingent Steven King
in the background he's one of the great
I read everything he does have to check
it out is he a king variant so he's not
a creation then I can give you cash I
don't need a receipt or anything yeah
but I have to ring it up
or
oh no I told you to stop putting your
sci-fi books on our shelves shut up a
what expecting in not provoking genre
well nobody buys it here oh so he's like
the elron
hopper
yes
oh oon Boris I love the utilization of
all these different locations
though all right science
OB this episode is titled science
fiction science SL
fiction ohic is he the inventure of the
TVA his is the most
similar
great re response CH s what I'm about to
tell you is going to be hard to believe
he'll believe it though he'll finish the
sentence for me of course I believe you
it's a dream come true one of my
characters has come to life and needs my
help reminds me of what happens in the
sons of uran my most popular book of all
time I'm sure I can find your copy
somewhere around here or Stranger Than
Fiction I had to get a PhD to keep my
day job teaching theoretical physics at
CCH you have no idea how hard it is to
breing hey look at this here's a Cy
you're are one lucky man you are one
lucky man I love all the yellow colors
here it's like what they last off Loft
you traveling to a place that doesn't
exist anymore is equally impossible and
therefore it's something you might be
able to do equally possible as well
doesn't sound like science no but it
does sound like
fiction you need to learn how to control
your time
slipping oh and they you can have
ultimate power Deja Vu you keep ending
up around exactly the people you're
looking for because you're not just
slipping in time you're also moving
around space not just physically a
better version of one of those Tamp
hats you make it sound like it's a good
thing could be with science it's all
what and how with Fiction it's why yeah
just do
it all right can you go back to that
moment where the Cliffhanger was of
episode three focus in on that why you
need to save the TVA if his why is
strong enough you need to save the TVA
because literally huning in on a
character's motivation their goal and
why very metac commentary way I mean
like he becomes the god of stories it's
interesting if this fiction narrative
becomes how he becomes the god of
Stories versus
Mischief I've been in this acting
class you must be doing something wrong
because it really feels like the time
sliping is the answer you're trying too
hard let go this equation proposes
a tase me bro now we know that
electrical pulses don't initiate time
slipping okay let's forget about the
time slipping time spping is clearly the
key maybe the place in time you're
looking for still exist but you just
don't know what to look for it hold this
yeah oh let's explain some complex
theoretical physics with props we get
the band back together every one of your
friends has a temple aa oh it's time to
recruit it'll be like coordinates and we
can use these coordinates to get back to
that moment in time
no we don't have one of those temp PS
you talked about well can you build one
I would have to invent it all from
scratch it could take a whole lifetime
oh we're watching a Time Loop here this
is how we got created wa he's the one
who created the temp pass he picked up
the journal though he's going to show
him his own Journey he's doing what Kang
did yeah yeah who exactly so Loki's
inventing the tva's beginning
yes yeah you wrote it so I am going to
write a bestseller this is all he who
remains plan I'm telling you that's why
he slipped to that moment to pick up the
book and then slipped again to gather
the people let's um so Kang is making
this happen hey just just let me that's
a problem just let me believe they're
going to fix this
guys no
K yes aadel Mobius any toy found outside
your room going to be classified as
garbage is he
burnt yeah he's burnt what is that
Brad Kevin who gave you the matches it's
Kevin feige time travel Kevin get Sean
go get him come
on did you follow me
home no no is that your my way to uh the
uh
I I'm sorry I couldn't stick around back
there I was um I was in a bit of a time
crunch you were good choice of worth are
you still in the market cuz I have
something I got something I want to show
you come here what do we
got he's a man of two jet skis a
beautiful Union of Form and Function
that's
lovely they really are and it breaks my
heart but you want a drink can I get you
a beer no no no I I'm fine thank you no
Mobius Mobius that's your name I think
you have me mixed up with someone else
now you see the thing is I don't Mobius
is your real name is it his real name
Mobius was his given name okay hold that
thought I'm going to go check on my okay
it's okay I don't want any is stranger
nature going on I'm a friend I know you
are I'm a friend
too jeez who how did you build a temp
pad so fast I don't know if I say 18
months is fast
well I had to take a break and move out
when I lost my job and my wife left me
you ruined his life
now that's so
funny
oh oo oh yeah I love the janky doorways
you saved my life when I first arrived
you saw something in me that I hadn't
seen in myself now it's time for you to
do the rescuing Loki are you really my
friend I am who's
he is he my
friend
the the TVA you once told me it was the
only life you'd ever known my jet SK man
he's got two sons what my boys they'll
be fine look you can come back the
moment you left oh you were uh you were
at the shop earlier right whoa your boys
W even know you're gone yeah but I
will
oh all of existence is in grave danger I
don't care your boys are in danger too
you're asking a father to give up all
this what were you calling
[Music]
meus it's a pretty cool
name yes it is it's interesting how
other than Obie everyone else kind of
feels a little bit antithetical to the
profession that we giving at the
TVA is going to sound strange she like
harms people instead of helps them he
does not know fun and he's a man who
gives fun Casey is sweet and innocent
where his her is a criminal
yeah I mean technically he's a fiction
writer who now makes science sure
science
[Music]
fiction the TV
Avengers
you've assembled a team very special
team I'm really enjoying the creativity
behind all of this there is one part of
me it's probably going to wait till
after the next episode is done and I'm
wondering if we should have spent a
little bit more time in the isolation
with Loki and trying to solve this we're
kind of just getting everyone
reassembled again really quick Fair
after such a cliffhanger eight 25
minutes later
stealing it's a what are we some sort of
temporal Squad
Don Opus is my space name space name is
this everyone no Sylvie and we are going
to need dinner I wonder if Sylvie
actually knows and remembers and is just
accepting all this she didn't want it I
could go for some hash browns o want to
make flurry pretty bad bless you thank
you McDonald's was really mad about that
canot show our food deteriorating it
lasts for
decades
save money on that show I know you don't
know who I am of course I know who you
are yeah what she has all of time as a
God she's seen more she would have seen
this their lives area after the Los yeah
I know I was there this isn't how I
thought the scene was going to play out
what exactly were you ex talk to a
Raider control it get in the car I'm
buying you a
drink how long has she been here M's
life at the TVA was taken from him so is
b15s OB Casey was prisoner
zaniac nice would have chosen to stay
the TVA was the only life he' ever known
gave him purpose it was never his choice
to begin with
Loki showing them something that they
cannot unsee didn't get a choice I can't
without
you I want a life I want to
live you work at
McDonald's that
ising but she can't travel no health
insurance maybe she Works enough I want
the TVA back and what do you want I want
my friends
back oh he doesn't want to be alone I
thought it was going to be you want to
be a hero he wants to be good I think he
wants her to I don't want to be
alone we're both
[Music]
selfish again consistently exploring
that gray your friends are back where
they
belong for all time always but without
them where do I belong we're all writing
our own stories
now start boy science fact maybe that's
why he was sort of just giving into the
whole TBA identity because he just
needed a place to belong this whole time
an anchor still a lost
boy you should all go home she's reading
this
book Guitar monkey rough day po better
rough life
this we either cure what's sailing you
or make it a whole lot worse
like good music
can good needle drop
shot what a toe blog off shot to her
head she has to like it's just like a
drug train spotting shot used musically
that was beautiful she just like dropped
in and dropped out to
music I wonder if they knew they were
going to use this song whoa what just
happened in the background there did
someone just time slip in and out oh
what's happening we are Frozen no we are
not
frozen
oh cups keep
[Music]
disappearing holy
[__] Sylvie take your headphones off
experience time dilations making it a
whole lot
worse whoa that's
cool
whoa no record store
guy it seems like she's immune to this
love how this is happening to like a
song that feels like a drug trip oh it's
definitely a drug trip oh
yeah
TV acid look at that shot man it looks
like parasitic the way it works yeah it
looks like like some kind of weird
fungus or like tapeworms or
something activate that pad
yep what about the TVA TVA you're fine
without it he lost his wife and
everything yeah no they
aren't everything's falling
apart oh we can go
back we can stop B Loom from melting
down they are going to go back just
immediately fix it I still think K got
canged up from that moment though we
need to read the collective temporal
Aura of everyone in this room on the
temp
P hey I didn't take it you can rob every
Bank you like when this is done we need
that temp pad now great but I still
didn't take it Frisk oh no no it's like
another version of getting dusted
absolutely
yeah it was a fic
problem time slip
intentionally come on man you got to
master the time slipping I have to go
back to see my
boys single father no is this
[Music]
it where do you go when you get
spaghetti there's nowhere left to
go oh not
immune I like how it feels like ghostly
in a way too so haunting and uncom like
there's a bit of a personality to it
it's ethereal yeah practicing my voice
Focus intentional your time slip go away
if I can go
anywhere follow the threads do you think
that what makes a loky a lowy is the
fact that we're destined to
lose he did it [__]
yeah go back a little bit
further yeah we can go back go back a
little bit
further everything's falling apart I was
such a cool edit but there must must be
something we can
do I did it what now is he the one that
takes the temp pad I did it did
[Music]
what I took the
almanac I made all the sports bets it's
not about where when
or why how what was it about it's about
who that was the last question
absolutely all of us Doctor Who I can
rewrite the story God of stories is born
God of
story wow we're going right back to
it right back to
it so they going to like try again and
fail multiple times yeah fail could be
like a doctor strange dorm yeah he's
come here to bargain with Kang yeah he's
just going to keep trying until they
figure it out I honestly think he's he
still under the plan of Kang if you
think about it he who remains wanted him
to rule the TVA and now he's got this
power of time more than anything else
you know damn he's been granted a brand
new power Loki he's going to oversee all
of the timelines yeah as the keeper or
is the god of stories ultimately he who
remains wins and then it doesn't factor
into any of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe yes no other's power is never
used again variety writes another
article about nothing sure to forward to
reading that culmination of three years
of nothing you got to contrive your news
from somewhere when no one's allowed to
work if that was a strike during the end
game it'd be like three days before
rapping then they wrote the ending for
Tony Stark last minute rewrites and I
think Miss minutes is still serving he
who remains his big plan and yeah I
think she's still in control boy wow a
lot to dissect here I can only
imagine that with the amount of
existential dread and those feelings of
loneliness that when you're thinking
about wow you need people in your life
you need some help you need some people
to talk to yeah and not just any kind of
help yeah you need best you know what
guys before we do the review I I think I
need to give a message to the audience
of course all right can can you guys
just leave for a second I'm going to
just just get out the frame let me just
do this today's episode is sponsored by
better help I know with that we often
joke around here quite a bit on the
channel but I wanted to speak a little
bit more sincere during this specific
sponsor and I'll start off by saying
this that you know with any sponsor they
usually give like suggested things to
consider uh when talking about the
sponsor and one of their suggested
things was was a question that they had
there that went along the lines of like
have you ever laid awake with your
thoughts racing wishing for a moment of
silence and I thought to myself well
yeah that's my secret cap I got know
that feeling way too well and it's in
those quiet moments where you're
battling your own mind where you are
seeking Clarity the most and you may
have heard me talk about this on the
channel before the better part of a
decade now therapy has undoubtedly been
one of my main anchors before there was
ever the real rejects I was diagnosed
with PTSD type 2 bipolar and ADHD so uh
needless to say I needed some therapy
and through its guidance I've Unearthed
deeper layers of myself cultivate a
richer relationships and just have a
more profound understanding of my
emotions and one of the best parts about
it is it's giving me a space where it's
free from judgment where I found my
voice and learned the art of truly
listening not just to others but also to
myself I've talked a little bit about
how this year I've focused a lot more on
my physical health and hitting the gym a
little bit more often and in all
sincerity I do view therapy as like the
a gym for your mental health a place
where you can really nurture your mental
well-being and it is an experience that
has been quite transformative so much to
the point that you know I would say say
at least half of the people that you see
that come here on the channel are in
therapy as a matter of fact I know one
of them their therapist is With Better
Health I often joke that like I've been
in therapy since it was underground why
I joke like that is because I I see now
in the past few years a lot more people
have been going to therapy which is
fantastic I'd love seeing that so I will
say that if in your heart if you have
been seeking therapy or contemplating
going to therapy I highly encourage you
I urge you to consider better help
before I ever saw some ad for better
help I had heard other people people who
had been with better help and had really
given strong in-person testimonies to me
their online platform is crafted with
care keeping your comfort in mind
starting it as simple as answering a few
questions and really important to
remember it's a journey and I really
love this because I've had at least like
three therapist in my life so if you
ever feel the need to change your
therapist better help understands and
allows it without any fuss trust me
that's a massive benefit so for a
journey of self-discovery and mental
well-being turn to betterhelp embark on
this heartfelt Joy at betterhelp.com
that's
I talked for quite a bit
there so many thoughts on the episode
out of that please John go Joe go John
Go I mean no go go Johnny
[Music]
Ranger you know I'm just glad take it
away
John I personally was quite enthralled
by this episode course you were you love
everything I love everything I don't
have any criticisms for read the Variety
article clearly
part of mar part story like this is all
Kevin's design whatever is the god of
stories in her world
yes no no the Variety article lady oh
that yes of course was like I'm gonna
read a lot of news and just put up one
article pretend it's new newo hey you
know
there's nearby there's an editor going
we need something the strike is on and
Marvel is popular but not as popular so
thus the perfect time yeah we can't talk
anymore about how DC is in champ there's
nothing new to report any who I really
enjoyed this episode uh I think yes I
need to dumb it down now John you trying
to play to the haters what's going on
pick a side John I thought this was a
rich existential experience oh now he's
an elite using big words like
existential uh it's good uh and sop how
do I be
sophisticated
where are the Easter eggs I need the Tik
Tock cut COI it's almost Christmas all
right a different holiday all together
Shane black Loki episode six yes
anyway okay for real that's my
review starting now I think that
certainly I may be the most enthralled
of us in some ways uh but you know like
I I don't know how people are going to
feel about like the pound-for-pound like
Revelations plot-wise as we got this
episode but uh I I've really really
really been loving and appreciating the
feeling that this show in particular has
been giving me that is kind of a rare
feeling it's the kind of feeling I
associate with like a par any
particularly rich and interesting sci-fi
and it comes with like stray episodes
particularly great Twilight zones or
things like that or like an amazing
Doctor Who uh something like this is
really embodying this sense of yeah
something is off and you can't quite
tell what the source of that is and it
permeates the mood of everything and I
really enjoyed the sort of somber lonely
mission that Loki was on this episode
seeing all of our different friends in
their you know potentially sacred
timeline lives I just I loved the mood
the aura the atmosphere and the puzzle
of figuring out the time slipping
figuring out should we or should we not
try and save the TVA why are we doing
that I just thought this was rich with a
lot of stuff I am often hoping that like
things like this so and then I'll let
you guys talk things like this are are
they make me kind of furious because I'm
like clearly you guys are capable of
coming up with something that is both
satisfying as like a big superhero you
know Blockbuster thingy but also that
has a really authentically science
fiction feel and level of thought and
meta thought put into it yeah um so
that's I thought that was was quite well
exemplified in this episode and even
though it might not be the most
revelatory in terms of like nuts and
bolts and plots um this might be towards
the top if I was to rank the episodes
for me might not be the top but it's
it's pretty close like I really loved a
lot of
this I uh almost kissed you there did
little mic to M little mic to mic little
syv Loki action uh I really like that
the show feels like it trusts us to take
its time I definitely had to adjust my
expectations about 10 minutes in when I
was like oh okay we're going to do like
a like a new um moment for our lead
versus the story directly carrying the
plot like we had to like charge up the
the narrative in the isolated
individuals in order for the big finale
and I actually once I realized that
really enjoyed the episode but there was
definitely a moment where I was like oh
we're rushing to this and then I was
like oh no we're slowing down for this
and I had to like reind of calibrate cuz
I I was was afraid it was going to do
what it did and then try to go back once
I realized what it was doing and I'm
really glad it just did what it did and
then like kind of let you breathe in the
emotional beats of that because it could
have been like and now we're back to the
TVA and I was like oh okay no we're
going to do this and give it some time
to breathe but I agree with John that
did cause it to not have as many
revelatory moments but it did give this
beautiful ponderous we all had these
moments of mentioning like The
Melancholy and the existential dread and
the man that that drop in Dropout song
of like your loose uh like LSD lucid
dreaming uh wonderful oh like there was
a weight to this episode early Doug I
also like that this season finally gave
Sylvie some time uh because I do feel
like we've missed out on a lot of Sylvie
um but I think the thing I like the most
is it was stuff that I thought was going
to happen from the jump that delivered
in a more fun way so like I I multiple
times in the episode was like this is
going to happen this going to happen but
then when it actually happened I was
like oh nice and like I called the god
of stories in the pilot but also like I
put out the comic rexs today like I
always do Midway through the season and
six seconds in is when he's first called
the god of stories because at the end of
the last episode I was like somehow
they're going to make that a thing I
thought it was going to be the finale it
ended up being here but they're doing a
beautiful thing kind of like Civil War
where they hit certain beats in the
comics in new ways and this is hitting
certain beats where I still think Victor
timy's demise is either the birth of
Kang or his manifesting into Kang I that
moment is not a negative for Kang and
I'm really excited to see that pay off
because I feel like I have all the
ingredients in the pie but I'm really
excited to see him bake it it's it's Dr
Doom now oh Dr Doom that's right right
so Dr Doom has been confirmed yeah the
and Robert T J showing
upet
Wars and also yeah don't worry about
it's going to be fun also blade is $100
million yeah and there's four
women the four I feel like blade would
be 100 Milli and M goth is the lead it's
very confusing Lake Bell's there too we
don't know why I mean we know blad did
disaster that's why it's out this year
right say none of it's new 2023 but uh
yeah think about the variety articles
and none of it's the it's literally just
repeating articles thing the thing we're
saying is like it's not that we disagree
with it it's that none of this is really
new it's also literally framed to be so
negative when it's like yeah we know
things have been bad why are you telling
us in one condense it's like now that's
what I call [__] like we know it's
[__] that's happening but they finally
confirmed that water is wet ah yes and
Marvel um anyway anyway uh I'm sure
we'll talk more about it on Saturday we
have a live stream we're doing um so
yeah I I I really I would rank this one
like my third favorite out of
the five four or five yeah
41532 yeah 41 uh yeah that's exactly
where I put it why we almost kissed
yeah I I would rank this uh number three
out of them and I I really did enjoy it
a lot and I agree with the entire
there's no point of me of repeating
everything you guys said repeat
everything yeah existential dread
Mel it was all great poetic it lovely I
I love that they gave us a few things
that we have been um sort of aiming for
and hoping for obviously Mobius on a jet
ski is something that we have all been
clamping at the bit like we want to see
that happen and I like the portrayals a
lot of what we got there's some I wish
we kind of got to live in a little bit
more I'll just say this I agree with all
the positives I think the right thing to
do when you're doing and say all the
positives and say they negatives or the
criticisms for later my criticism about
it is more so wondering how I'll
ultimately feel about it in the end once
episode 6 is done because you know one
thing that has come out about Marvel
lately but now that they've officially
finally hired some showrunners is that
they've essentially been making movies
and then dividing it up into like
several hours and whereas here Loki I
would say that they they really do feel
like they have thought episode per
episode and where each episode should
really end and I don't feel like that
none any of them have been filler
they've all felt substantial and
necessary what was missing for me like I
love the turns that we've got in here I
love the answers I like how this was a a
big Journey on Loki really establishing
like in season one he was understanding
his own true identity and here he was
understanding connection and that these
people are really a big part of his
camaraderie and that the key to the time
slipping and understanding that a lot of
this is a power from within it's not
just something that is happening to him
I think is great I really love learning
that and watching all all of that UNF I
think Tom Hilson gives another great
performance what was missing for me that
I actually do feel is a bit rushed is
you get such a great Cliffhanger of what
has happened to the TVA what has become
of everyone lok's the only one who
really remembers and it's this journey
that I don't really feel a sense of
catharsis on
because it's the the journey is about
like getting the team back together and
getting them to remember
reassembling and uh you know they talk a
lot about goals and wise here and
putting them on the path for why to do
this and I I kind of feel like we got to
assembling them all pretty much like
really quick and not letting us live in
the I guess the the hopelessness of the
situation enough if this wasn't a Marvel
show I would have liked an eight episode
series and i' had I'd had one of of
filler not filler in the negative sense
but filling in the time between Brad and
the interrogation like like or make that
episode like two-parter and then I would
have loved this to be a two-parter
between his isolation and then a longer
rallying of the troops yeah like really
if I'd make it eight those are the two
beats you would you would uh you could
let the debate linger a little bit
longer of why they should come together
of why of the sacrifices that are
potentially at hand like Loki's not Loki
Mobius is family uh like we didn't
really get to see B1 15's life and the
moment where he accepts that he needs
others got moved quickly it I I wanted
that to like stick and I get that that's
the The Epiphany but I I like when that
has a resolution because that's the
moment we have I guess what was missing
for me was a little bit of the drama a
little bit of the struggle and to me it
kind of
got it's it it was to the point where I
was like well we know that we're going
to be resolving this and I feel like
there was too much of an awareness on
the writer's end to be like we know
they're going to resolve this so let's
just get to it and I I feel like we need
in order to feel the catharsis of them
finally coming back together of them
finally doing this you need to have a
moment where you were not feeling the
finally it was just more like we know
we're getting there and we started
getting there within like 10 minutes I
hope they don't fix it next episode man
I feel like so so that's my I know know
I know I I know out of the three of us I
spent like the most time you know
gestating on a uh on a criticism that I
had and a desire but but I would still
rank this number three because
everything that I liked about it is the
thing same things I would Echo that you
guys said Echo trailer apparently coming
out Yay good job Marvel over Market
everything all at once and so all the
episodes are already
live thei
finale finale before marveles comes out
put it on Tik Tok in 15 seconds
we need to compete with the fact that
Invincible is also premiering at the
same
time two things at good thing they're
not both on Amazon we want to have a I
think that's di so yeah that is my that
is my one concern but again I love the
tone I love the symmetry of these shots
I loved Obie's performance I like where
the theories let you speculate towards
this it feels like they're actually
giving you a reward with that a lot of
times with a lot of these Marvel shows I
think what ends up happening and maybe
Co still doing it too much to a certain
extent you know where you like over
theorize was in this episode he was all
over this episode
right but I would say that they they do
within this season alone they eventually
like lean into things where like oh damn
some crazy theories are coming true you
know like I the thing I'm really
latching on to is that we are watching
he who remains ultimate plan unveil in
fact when you look at the previously on
the first thing they open up with
something from he who remains talking
about like this is the plan and
eroded I was like I'm pretty confident
that whatever everything is a uh mislead
of of heroic conquering or heroics
climbing up the ladder that everything
that we think is heroism is really a
step of the direction yes I think that
is exactly what we're watching unfold is
something truly malevolent what if they
build the timeon for him like what if
that's what his power like what if
putting it back together is what allows
him to con need to build my bigger it
can't end well I don't think it could I
I don't think it will end well um and
and that's what I I've been that's what
I've been really loving about the show
um and the performance is all around so
in this episode in the background there
was a 25 and the 25 in the time theater
this episode five five times time is 25
but in issue 75 a wolverine gets Adam
man takeen out X-Men 75 25 time 3
Deadpool three he's in the next episode
Wolverine
confirmed yeah Dead 3 25 is 75 Adam anti
pull down that's how you used to
convince me but then now I just go I'd
like to rather be here and be like oh
[__] Koy was right no you're my story
for right my story also the second Ora
Boris I love that he's an Ora Boris for
Kang as well as an or Boris for Loki
like the Ora Boris of Loki giving him
the f starts of the time and then him
needing Ora Boris to bounce off the time
so he's an or Boris for good and evil
making him a true chaotic neut which is
time travel I think they could have used
a third beat of obie of like of develop
it his life crumbling off screen oh so
funny that was that was hilarious lost
my wife lost my wife my home I 18 months
fast I know yeah you could a third one
would have been H I just I thought that
was so funny well that's the thing is I
I I would agree across the spectrum that
yeah it's like if you had given if you'd
given this Eight Episodes I think you
would have I think they're doing a
really nice job of moving this along in
a six episode package that doesn't feel
strange and lopsided and and funky and
all that stuff like they're they're
still doing a really good job with the
brevity however you know yeah you would
love some more of those just more time
to fill in those beats something you
said earlier made me think of or just
like an hour and 10-minute episode
instead of a 40 minute yeah yeah it made
me kind of think uh what you what you
said a few minutes ago is like they're
writing as if they know that we know
that these certain things are for oron
conclusions and I think that in a lot of
in a lot of places it's okay to do that
if you know some conclusion is coming
you don't necessarily need to drag it
out however I feel like in an
environment like this in in the MCU
especially I would argue it's kind of
important to spend a little time within
the circumstances even if we know what
the outcome might become and so yeah
like I think this show is good at doing
that in general however I I would agree
that those
certain beats I would have been thrilled
to live even more in or even early on in
the episode when he's running around
like that reminded me of that where is
everybody Twilight Zone episode and like
you could have done even more of that
you know you could have I wanted more
Mobius in his single dadhood I wanted
more of you know 15 like the way how you
lived in the life of an endgame when
you're seeing like okay it's bad for
some people but like look at Tony
Stark's life it's actually all right put
at risk and he's got a debate here
whether or not
we barely met his kids like and I didn't
feel the weight of if he lost them yes
and and I think we didn't feel any of
the weight of Loki wondering is he
making the right call either because the
lack aweight of their own individual
choices I feel like there should have
been a part of him that was hearing
sylv's argument yeah and I feel like
that Epiphany would have been stronger
of how it landed it's like we know they
like obviously we know we
know oh man oh the comments right now
like they're really picking this apart
they're being like we're just saying
what could make it
it's still really effective really rich
still significantly better than like 99%
of the Maring things that like would
have jued did a little bit more yeah
it's and it like for me this is living
up to and and carrying on the greatness
from the first season like still this is
still like topnotch like this is the
capability this is what I want this is
you know the stuff I know you can make
great um but yeah yeah it's just like
when you Glimpse that greatness you're
like you know what can make this even
greater
Mobius we don't know his last name might
be storm stopping a Time storm kid bull
cut matches Human Torch Johnny Storm
fantastic for confirmed that's right see
it's all in this one episode it's an Ora
Boris of Easter eggs um yeah this was a
this was this is still still like my
favorite Marvel show that they have here
and um I I don't I don't want OB to to
have like an e evilness reveal and I'm
afraid that will happen
I I don't know if it's intentional
because he's clearly pulled out
of like he clearly had a life
here yes but part of me W he's so
removed isolated and like and strange by
comparison to everyone else he's the
only one who doesn't feel quite like
they were just always at this point on
their time line sure sure and I mean and
that could just be me reading into it
because on the other hand you could just
be like oh he's just an exentric
you know guy who spends a lot of time
alone and just got divorced you know
right but I could also see it working in
a way where yeah there's something more
Sinister to him but I I I I love I
really do love uh what they've done what
they've given kiwan to work with in this
because he is the perfect presence for
this agree and in this episode I thought
he he really shown out and I loved what
they did with him and Loki breaking down
how to think about this as science
versus fiction and all that other stuff
yeah the word play was as dynamic as the
Owen Wilson stuff and that's impressive
like the fact that I'm just as invested
in as two men talking in a room as I was
with the the mobia stuff that that's the
power of that character yeah yeah I
still yeah I can't I can't help but feel
like we do need a little bit more flesh
on some of the like especially with
Sylvie this was the closest all we ever
get is just her like working at
McDonald's going I want a normal life
but you don't really get to see like
what the appeal is what she has to hold
on to that music choice and and two like
it's a very effective sequence so like
her turn makes a lot of sense but you
know like we do kind of go from her
convincing Loki that this is his own
selfish Mission and then you know
recanting on that pretty quick that said
for how how much we want those things it
is impressive the writing and the actors
are able to give us enough with the
limited time that that drawing out scene
felt so powerful like I want to give
credit to the visual effects artists and
the actors and the writer and directors
because what they even with the limited
time that we're wanting more of I was
still like oh when they all got like
time Bal I appreciate the fact that
they're at least even given the [__]
effort and and and like you can feel
that like they probably want to do all
these things oh 100% I guarantee there's
a mandate of like you only have six
episodes and stuff so I wouldn't it's
not something where I actually blame the
writers no no and for and for wishing
for that stuff I don't think it's
hurting for it like I still thought this
was great I still loved so much of this
it again it's that thing of like this
was so good and and you can just easily
see the potential for even more of that
goodness yeah I love the look at time
dusting that's what I'm going to leave
and we're going to get probably more
Jonathan Majors next episode yeah yes
it's Time Magazine dreams let's do it I
think they should air his uh trial on
the on the same day oh well but Disney
plus make an exclusive they should put
it on all the screen the T how crazy
with that but air on the same time
invincible and geny while the Marvels is
playing in theaters that's oh yeah it's
the same day guys November 9th I think
they should do it no they should drop
the Marvel the Echo trailer it's not
oversaturation it's it's over they just
release too much at once why compete
with others when you can compete with
yourself why spread out your release
dates just everyone release your [__]
all at the same time it's for
fun it's nice we love it they're like we
need to to get all this stuff out here
so we can take a nice long break when
nothing is left after these strikes all
righty guys what did you think about all
this leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe for our reaction to
the finale thank you qu for being here
thank you to better help again for uh
partnering up with us and hey uh we
didn't shout out some patrons we got to
make up for that let's do it all right
guys part two that is going up after
Halloween yes but we have to finish it
so where we left off okay was John have
put into chat gbt the way how John has
figured out how to write everything and
anything including text messages to his
friends family when someone he go what
do I say and uh I'm trying to console my
grieving relative my therapist has a
question for me and here it is chat gbt
so what was the prompt you gave it I
told chat gbt uh we're going to shout
out our patrons our super sexy rejects
for the month of October and the theme
will be a Halloween party we want you to
come up with funny or scary movie
related costumes for each Patron based
on their name so that's the general idea
yes and uh we have about like 10 15 more
names to go and I intentionally I was
very purposeful about I want to react to
them on camera I don't know fresh I
don't know them either what they are
suggesting so R past Nick X let's pull
it up all right and let's see left off a
Nick X last time that's right all right
one Longoria one the werewolf only
transforms during fiestas not bad that
is
racist that is a racist prompt chat gbt
made a quick extrapolation and the rest
is based off of that all right Cliff
Rodriguez as Cliff the living mummy uh
wrapped and ready to party oh the party
mummy Cliff I love it and think of all
the things he could be wrapped in that
are like party ready you know that's
clever goat Nation goat nation's Goatman
half man half oh that makes a lot of
sense half man half goat all party
animal yeah the goatman's here dude it's
like chupacabra distant cousin I love it
uh hey how about Lorenzo Baxter Lorenzo
the lurking Lagoon monster likes to
photob bomb underwater selfies it's a
very high effort costume there wow I
hope Lorenzo would have to go underwater
take selfies to make sure he could show
them at parties to everyone be like
what's your costume I go here look look
at my phone look at my phone look how
many people I photob
bombed was that you that was me oh it's
me now runs of back it's differently
Sayan as Norman Bates quirky twin okay
sure chat gbt like I don't F know CH G
really put a lot of work in the first
half of the list do I see him
predictable fun sure why not you know
Norman B
could brother cousin whatever how are
you supposed to write my Avengers Secret
Wars movie if you're coming up a crap
like this it's okay they're going to
reboot the whole thing in chat gbt is
going to come up with the the structure
of the phases it's going to be great
Marco tons Marco the murderous mime his
silence is deadly that I think is a
pretty solid one yeah it does all the
M's what's that called alliteration
alliteration yeah Lauren American where
he said plus though what oh I mean just
I don't know like to have the power to
command a room in complete silence
especially at a Halloween party like
that's that's no small feat yeah only
two people can do that Nick Cage and
Judy DCH Lauren American horse as Lauren
the Ghost
Rider I love that yeah because Ghost
Rider part of his history one of the
early Ghost Riders has a horse her Steed
a phantom stallion that is clever
well that's well done yeah well done
write the Ghost Rider read I bet it
could I bet it could hey simply faded uh
as the ghost of 9s
Trends watch out he'll bring back
frosted tips I love it and those
snapping bracelets and and uh scooter
Razor
scooters SJ
94 SJ 94 the slasher because old horror
villains need SE equals
what you know because uh Why didn't it
just be like the 94 horror movie
amalgamation villains you should have
just done every
v44 that would have been better C jez we
give it the prompt to say that to the
camera John so that way chat gbt knows
directed gbt I know you're watching this
and collecting this information do
better next time simply faded oh my God
I read the next one it it's great oh oh
I mean s94 yeah that's right this is
Justin Martin is Justin the jack o
lantern
Jester glows in the dark that's clever
yeah plus that's called an alliteration
hey dude it is good job well done I
learned something new today and also
Justin Lantern lit up our day or just
just Martin justtin the Jacko Lantern
Jester uh lit up our day yeah a nice
glow-in-the-dark costume I like it well
guys now you know what to be for October
2024 do not disappoint no never
disappoint never give up never surrender
Home Improvement yep we love you guys
stay pledged and we'll catch you next
time for what I assume will be the
Thanksgiving version of
this
let it live there were more we forgot
whoops didn't forget scoll forgot a
scroll yep Rosy BTY tarota
066 hey this is cool Rosie the Sith
witch mixing galaxies in Magic since the
Clone Wars that's that is a uh timely
for now especially Victor timely because
of um not timely relevant cuz we finally
got witches yeah
damir Rosie of damir I like it dude
Colin Colin oh this one's a good one
especially in the age of the bear Colin
the cannibal Chef
Corner his dishes are to die for sweet
sauce yeah love it oh my God he could
give everyone at the party like actual
food yeah or human Philip J Smith junor
Philip The Phantom of the Disco haunting
dance floors everywhere oh he could be
like a disco version of The Phantom of
the Opera yeah he be the Phantom of The
Paradise he could be exactly that Jen
Smith oh my God though the fro yeah uh
Jen Smith Jen the jump scare Jester dude
we can have dueling Jesters at this
party don't play her haunted games I
think I'd like to play our haunted games
I think we would all like to play Jen's
haunted as we mess up with these names
Melanie LeBlanc
last one the real last one Melanie the
malevolent mermaid hey deep just the
titles you could just be like I'm a
mermaid but once you say I'm melany the
malevolent mermaid suddenly it sounds
inventive yeah you'd be like a a
Sinister formidable mermaid deep sea
horror stories abound yeah there should
be more of those kinds of mermaids oh
yeah you could be like looking beautiful
and then you open your mouth and you got
them like crazy siren Mermaid teeth
Jagged spiky ones just like blood all
over your your your mermaid tail yeah
gets your period twice a month yeah and
you can come with like yep definitely
it's always blood in the water with this
Mermaid come in with a harpoon through
you somewhere should have ended at
Justin Martin n n this was where it was
always meant to go now it's really done
yes